hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 10 video they
did a whole bunch of comic book stuff so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet
all the big shippers out there just walk
around high-fiving each other for all
the sex congratulations I'm sure you've
been waiting on this for a long time
hopefully it lasts plus do top 10 WTF
I'll explain the comic book stuff and
the Easter eggs as we go along and there
is a new round of the walking dead
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so here we go everything is
fine there's some awesome music playing
nick is fixing his belt and Carl's out
of the infirmary it's just the show
trying to tell you that everything is
good everything is positive the people
that are left are coming together as
family now and nowhere is that more
obvious than the number 9 WTF Michonne
walks out of the bathroom in her towel
and Rick makes a joke about how they've
been hanging out she's been using up all
the water for a long time so she's been
living there this whole time it's almost
like they're family they're been all
kinds of jokes for the last couple of
seasons about how Michonne is the mom in
this equation with Rick and Carl being
the son baby Judith being her children
this is just the next logical step them
living in domestic bliss and each time
they came back to seem like this like
the Michonne mom theme just get hammered
home even stronger even more number 8
WTF though Daryl as he's going around
asking people for what they need talks
to Denise she asked for soda why does
she need a soda because Tara's been
talking about soda in her sleep boom the
show turns another ship into an actual
thing the show totally went there this
week with so many relationships it's
like the Tumblr episode of Walking Dead
the number 7 WTF Rick and Daryl out on
their road trip looking for supplies
looking for people they mentioned that
it's been a couple weeks they haven't
seen anyone law of averages they have to
catch a break sometime soon I guess they
haven't been finding a lot of stuff but
they find a cachet of supplies in the
back of a truck that's almost too good
to be true like you keep waiting for
someone to jump out and try and shoot
him in the face which they eventually
meet in number 6 WTF meet Jesus so this
is Paul Monroe from the comic books he
leads to a big place that we haven't
been to yet so I'll say spoiler warning
or if you've read the comics and you
want to talk about the place that he's
from just please use spoiler tags in the
comments because it's gonna be a big
reveal probably in next week's episode
maybe the week after that I actually
thought we were gonna see that place in
this week's episode but I guess they're
teasing it out using jeez
this I thought the show did a pretty
good job of giving you an idea of who he
is he's a complete badass and he's a
good person
Rick says it himself as he's talking to
Daryl did he ever try to pull a weapon
on you burr Rick and Darrell are totally
in the right to not trust him the teaser
for next week's episode makes it seem
like they will have that sit-down with
him where he'll explain himself I know I
said spoiler warning for that place that
he's from in the comics just for the
benefit of people in case you haven't
read the comic books he's kind of like
the Aaron of the place that he comes
from he's a scout for the place that
he's from he goes that looks for other
people looks for supplies but he's a
total badass he's gonna be a really
awesome character on the show so get
hype for Jesus I love people are gonna
be like walking around saying this now
anyone that doesn't understand Walking
Dead is gonna think that you found
religion or something like that or
you're like a born-again Christian
number five WTF
Carla needed having a picnic out in the
woods she's starting to fade I think
she's slowly becoming more socialized
like it's probably gonna be a while but
the way they play the scene makes it
seem like Carl's gone completely nuts
even though we learned later that he's
remarkably well-adjusted given what's
happened to him I mean he met he meant
had a fully process that yet but the way
they play the scene is really fun there
are a couple of different types of
tricks that the Walking Dead TV show
plays that I like some that I don't like
so much the thing that I did not like
during this scene was when they start
arguing with their backs to the walker
like they know the walkers coming but
they turn around and start shoving each
other and then you get the jump scare of
the walker grabbing Carl that has
happened so many times where like a
character sees a walker coming they're
like okay I'm gonna get him but then
they get distracted the camera turns
around so you don't see the walker
approaching them until finally like the
Walker grabs in and they're like oh my
god they gotta fight him off but you get
this big WTF because Carl's like we
can't kill this Walker you don't
understand
notice that he is not wearing the
comic-book eyepatch yet number four WTF
Michonne helps Spencer bury Deanna turns
out Deanna was the Walker that Carl
would not kill leads her back to the
safe zone and then later explains -
Michonne that he needed to be someone
who was family that killed her I
completely agree with the logic it gives
Spencer's character closure it seems
like they're taking his character in a
slightly different direction than the
comic book the comic book version of his
character is a little more underhanded
so it seems like they're taking tv-show
Spencer in a slightly more positive
direction but it's a great moment and it
sets up this big speech that Michonne
has about family where your family now
in this episode in general is really
about family everyone
coming together all the people left are
even more family than they were before
and in some cases it becomes a much more
literal thing number three WTF Carl
explains Tim has shown that she is
family now I feel like it's been implied
for the last couple of seasons
Michonne emotionally adopted Carl and
Judith Carl telling her I love you
you're my family
is just making it even more literal so
if you weren't really picking up the
rashon vibe at the beginning of the
episode this is just making it even more
of a thing number two WTF Rick and Carl
bring Paul back to the safe zone I love
the funny way they play this where
Rick's like you were never gonna leave
him behind in the bumps in the road keep
making him fall on Daryl he keeps
shoving him off let their two kids in
the back seat during a car ride get off
a minute that's my gun Daryl's like an
outdoor feral cat they're not really
quick to accept others into the group
but the whole experience with Jesus is
just complete hilarity I mean it's kind
of WTF when you first meet him because
you're like oh my god he stole the truck
but then they chase him down in this
funny music starts playing in the
background is they're trying to shake
him off the top of the band really
excited about Jesus and I love the way
they used his skills for comedy like he
just shows up and Rick and Michonne
spent hey We Need to Talk bro and of
course number one WTF Rick and Michonne
are now officially Rishon the TV show
totally went there tumbler exploded that
rumble in the distance is the sound of
tumblers servers going down from too
much traffic
of all the ways the TV show messes with
you I just I love the way they filmed
the scene with Rick at the end of the
night like he was coming home from a
hard day at work like oh honey I had
this terrible day at work he takes his
boots off it's almost like this Norman
Rockwell painting come to life you know
Michonne's like scoot over let's look at
the baby isn't that cute cut to holding
hands looking at each other and you know
immediately where it's going cut to them
waking up in bed hey hey wake up wake up
in the way they both simultaneously bolt
out of bed bug ass naked was hilarious
it was so perfect I'm not even a big
shipper on the show like I'm not a big
Rishon shipper but I love the way they
did this it was so funny and it's the
logical progression of their characters
the way the producers explain it is if
they had been building towards this the
characters had been building momentum
for a long time
and now that they were out of crisis it
was like everyone was coming together
and Rick and Michonne were just letting
their guard down and letting this thing
happen that maybe they had wanted
previously but because of all the
craziness just
completely put off and I know a lot of
you are worried about her now because
it's like once you have sex you've
broken the rule of a horror film so
you're like oh man does this mean
Michonne's gonna die not necessarily but
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the episode
was that all the rashon stuff was that
all the Jesus stuff it's gonna be so
much fun and just to be clear re shown
is not a comic book thing rick and
michonne ever got together in the comic
books what's gonna happen is this next
week will probably also be a big comic
book episode so you want to read the
comics you can actually start with the
first issue that Jesus appeared in that
was issue number 91 in another big comic
book Easter egg it's not a walking dead
Easter egg
but the comic book that Carl is reading
is invincible that is also a comic that
Robert Kirkman writes so high-fives to
Robert Kirkman for product placement and
giveaway winner congratulations to last
week's giveaway from my episode 9 video
goose Willis just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for last week's
episode of The Walking Dead and you can
click here for the Game of Thrones
season 6 long night video that I just
posted thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you